[Music]
our national security lawyers in the
White House that worked for me work for
the president they're slicing and dicing
it looking at it so that we know what
what it means and what it understands
you see he wants everything out so the
American people can make up their own
minds and if there's people to be held
accountable then so be it but it'll be
released here pretty quick I think and
Everett the whole world can see it
nothing is so repugnant and frightening
it's the Republican all-out assault on
law enforcement and particularly our FBI
it really hasn't been this much coverage
of a memo no one's seen publicly I don't
think ever this memo is likely coming
out but the FBI pushing back releasing a
statement saying the FBI takes seriously
its obligations to the FISA Court its
compliance with procedures overseen by
career professionals in the Department
of Justice and the FBI we were committed
to working with the appropriate
oversight entities to ensure the
continuing integrity of the FISA process
with regard to the house intelligence
committees memorandum the FBI was
provided a limited opportunity to review
this memo on the day before the
committee voted to release it as
expressed during our initial review we
have grave concerns about material
omissions of fact that fundamentally
impact the memos accuracy to which the
house Intel Jer Devon Nunez responded
with this statement the memo contains
all the relevant facts on file abuse
after fighting our demands for these
documents for months the FBI and DOJ now
seemed to be going through a series of
increasingly ridiculous increasingly
desperate excuses to avoid transparency
so where are we on all this and what
does it mean let's bring in our panel
former CIA analyst at nationally
syndicated radio host buck Sexton Philip
bump politics reporter for The
Washington Post and bill magrunner
mainstream columnist for The Wall Street
Journal okay buck the arguments the FBI
clearly laying down a marker here saying
this is what they feel Chris ray and
others large federal bureaucracies are
always going to spend at least some of
their energy and time defending
themselves especially in circumstances
where there could be something
embarrassing that
comes out now as you've pointed out we
haven't seen the memo yet so we're doing
a lot of debating of something that we
don't have the full facts on but I would
just note that at this point what is
really the other option are we just
going to pretend that this hasn't
happened this national discussion isn't
ongoing and we're not going to see
what's in this memo if someone's to talk
about undermining faith and institutions
it would seem to seem to me that
withdrawing Congress's ability and
obligation to do oversight here and then
hoping that this just goes away is the
worst of all options the better option
is for it to come out Democrats can
respond the FBI can add the context that
they think is necessary and the American
people can finally know there's a
presidency at stake here speaker Ryan
seemed to indicate it that the
Democratic version of the memo was going
to go through the same process and
likely will come out as well having the
members he at first Dianne Feinstein
senator Feinstein says it's clear the
goal is to undermine the special
counsels investigation
if transparency were the objective
Republicans would support releasing the
Democratic memo simultaneously but
instead they're blocking it there's no
excuse for playing politics with the
highly classified information president
shouldn't place personal or partisan
interests above our national security I
mean I think I explained the series of
end events as the speaker describes them
going through this process yeah I mean I
think that the the question that sort of
sort of overhangs all of this is the
question of urgency what is the urgency
at play here why is it that the memo to
the point the buck just made yes if you
release the memo then this information
is out there this is the argument that
chief of staff John Kelly made this
morning but the FBI has expressed
concerns about the contents of the memo
repeatedly on more than one occasion
even today the Department of Justice
Roberts esteemed the Deputy Attorney
General indicated that he shared those
concerns that the FBI had and the
question I think the broader question
here is and the question that that I
think you see reinforced by what does
senator Feinstein just said is why isn't
it the case that there is a unified
document that comes out potentially from
the Republicans and the Democrats
articulating what concerns there may be
with the FISA process and have that be
the thing that is presented to the
public instead of what is admittedly I
think on all sides the work product of
the Republicans on the House
Intelligence Committee bill
ya know I think that the FBI's argument
is ridiculous for one thing they've
shifted the argument they used to say
with sources and methods now they're
saying basically it would be material
embarrassing to us this is the Colonel
jessep argument from a few could men the
American people can't handle the truth I
think people need to see we have two big
questions over all this did Donald Trump
collude with the Russians to steal the
election in 2016 and did the FBI and DOJ
put their fingers on the scale now
remember this is also christopher ray in
his testimony for confirmation spoke
about how he couldn't give Congress
information because it was classified
this gets us backwards you know the FBI
is accountable to we the people through
the Congress not the other way around
but it seems like it's coming to a head
we're hearing it could be tomorrow that
this all moves forward the president
indicated as he was walking out of the
State of the Union address a hundred
percent it's coming out what do you
think the fallout will be if the FBI
objections you know if it really does
make the FBI and the DOJ look as bad as
some Republican lawmakers suggest it
does well I think that gets us into a
critical distinction that the White
House and others have been trying to
make for a while now which is that there
is no war on the FBI there is no effort
to undermine wholesale the Department of
Justice and all that it does this is
about the actions of a few individuals
that were in very senior levels at both
those institutions and bringing them to
light so that there can be
accountability there has to be to the
point that was just made Congress has
oversight here these are not a separate
an independent branch of government and
so that's why I think the transparency
issue here there really doesn't seem to
me to be a worthwhile counter-argument
I'm not seeing it especially given that
now they're saying we need our own memo
to come out well is it that it was
classified or is it that you want your
own say right it's trying to separate it
though from the counts special counsels
investigation seems a little tough the
speaker tried to walk that line
yesterday it's all interconnected here
isn't it yeah I mean it certainly seems
to me and again we've said this 100
times but we don't know what's even the
memo so it's a little hard we don't know
no exactly but that said it is clear
that one of the concerns that has been
raised about this memo is the extent to
which the White House in particular is
enthusiastic about its release because
it will cast doubt upon the entire
process the president Trump is facing
that is clearly an aspect to it and so I
think that speaker Ryan was trying to be
deliberate and saying this is something
separate from that to try and erase that
that that sense that may be out there I
mean all of that said I mean I think
that this is we're being asked
essentially by politicians to trust that
they are the objective actors here
whereas the trained FBI officials who
are trained to act objectively are the
ones that are acting on a partisan basis
I think that's a tough sell for a lot of
America the only problem is is it
changed with these text messages and
when the text message came out it
painted a different picture I'd rather
hear people concerned not about urgency
but about truth and there are serious
questions raised about the FBI if the
FBI misrepresented information in a FISA
Court the premiere law enforcement
agency in the world that is a big deal
because it if if they change the 302
forms which are with the interview forms
that is a big deal that gets to the
heart of the government I mean it's to
me it's worse than if a politician's
corrupt politicians corrupt it's one
thing if these objective institutions
and I I just find it so strange that
never have so many fought so hard to
prevent so much information from coming
out it seems to me that all the
arguments whether it's lack of context
or that it was put together I want to
know whether it was true and if it
requires more information yeah he
answered me I want that I want to see
the Democratic memo the I want to see
the IG report I want to see it out and
remember this is an FBI that has fought
giving this information and the only
reason that they acceded to it is
because they were threatened the
director was threatened with the
contempt vote in Congress